[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport ein schöner von mir
schauen wir auf die Nachrichtenthemen
von heute
die Folgen des Dammbruchs im
ukrainischen Überflutungsgebiet kämpfen
die Menschen gegen die Wassermassen vor
allem drohen massive Schäden für die
Landwirtschaft
Manöver über Deutschland ab Montag probt
die Luftwaffe gemeinsam mit
Partnerländern den Ernstfall die größte
luftübung in der Geschichte der NATO
und Triumph in der Relegation Wehen
Wiesbaden steigt in die zweite
Fußball-Bundesliga auf für Bielefeld ist
es der zweite Abstieg in Folge
[Musik]
erst krieg jetzt dazu die Flut nach dem
Dammbruch in der Ukraine müssen weiter
Menschen vor dem Wasser fliehen die
Behörden warnen vor solchen und
Krankheiten hunderttausende haben nach
Angaben des ukrainischen Präsidenten
keinen normalen Zugang mehr zu
Trinkwasser
auf einer Länge von etwa 100 Kilometer
sind die Menschen am Flusslauf von den
Überschwemmungen betroffen sowohl auf
der nördlichen Flussseite im
ukrainischen Teil als auch im russisch
besetzten Süden ein Beispiel aus der
Ortschaft krinky diese Satellitenbilder
von vorher und nachher zeigen dass der
ganze Ort überflutet wurde
dramatisch ist die Situation auch in der
Stadt herson am Nordufer von dort
berichtet Tim Krüger
schon am frühen Morgen sind die
Evakuierungen in vollem Gang mit Boten
und Spezialfahrzeugen vor allem viele
ältere Menschen sitzen noch in ihren
Wohnungen fest die von den Wassermassen
umschlossen sind nur ein paar
Habseligkeiten haben sie dabei oft ihre
Haustiere es ist ungewiss wann sie
zurückkehren können wir werden nicht
sterben wir sind während der Zeit
geblieben als die Stadt beschossen wurde
und jetzt auch noch das aber es wird
schon gehen wir werden bis zum Sieg
durchhalten
unklar ist die Lager auf der anderen der
russisch besetzten Seite des Niko weite
Teile sind überflutet wir sehen Häuser
die unter Wasser stehen
ist von der anderen Seite mit ihrer
Mutter gekommen von den Russen wollte
sie sich nicht evakuieren lassen sie ist
mit dem eigenen Boot übergesetzt
die Russen sind gestern abgezogen wir
haben dann alle in der zweiten Etage
übernachtet das Wasser stieg aber bis
dahin und dann haben wir den Fluss auf
eigenes Risiko überquert
der Stadtteil ist von den Wassermassen
besonders betroffen allein hier mussten
hunderte Menschen in Sicherheit gebracht
werden am Mittag macht sich der
ukrainische Innenminister ein Bild von
der Lage vor allem die ökologischen
Folgen könnten verheerend sein sagt er
wenn die chemischen Abfälle ins Schwarze
Meer gelangen wird das eine Katastrophe
nicht nur für die Ukraine sondern für
den ganzen Schwarzmeerraum
die Folgen des dammbrust könnten in der
Region noch jahrelang zu spüren sein
noch gibt es keine Zahlen zu Toten oder
Verletzten und auch keine Gewissheit wer
oder was für den Dammbruch
verantwortlich ist die wichtigste
Auswirkung auf den Kriegsverlauf ist
wohl dass die Wassermassen den
ukrainischen Vormarsch ausbremsen aber
auch russische Verteidigungslinien
stehen unter Wasser und die Folgen für
Menschen Wirtschaft und Natur sind
gewaltig Christian Volk
mehr als knöchelhoch steht das Wasser im
Haus von Valerie Melnik erlebt auf der
südlichen russisch besetzten Seite des
nipro
wir dachten vielleicht kommen die
örtlichen Behörden und helfen uns das
Wasser aus dem Haus zu pumpen sie
könnten das ja machen aber niemand tut
etwas
während Valerie auf Hilfe wartet
veröffentlicht das russische
Staatsfernsehen diese Bilder Busse die
Anwohner aus der Region bringen sollen
ein kurzzeitiges Problem die Versorgung
mit Trinkwasser ein tiefer gehendes die
zerstörte Landwirtschaft ohne
Wasserkraftwerk könnte die Kornkammer
der Welt in Teilen eine Wüste werden
ich sehe dass dieser Bruch der Staudamms
enorme Folgen haben wird für die
Landwirtschaft in der Produktion der
fünf größte exporthöhe der Welt der
ohnehin enorm unter Druck ist durch den
Krieg wird noch weiter unter Druck
gesetzt und das wird verheerende
Auswirkungen haben für die
Lebensmittelsicherheit weltweit auch die
Suche nach den Verantwortlichen für den
Dammbruch geht weiter bei den Vereinten
Nationen in New York ohne Erfolg vor dem
Sicherheitsrat schoben sich Russland und
die Ukraine gegenseitig die Schuld
vorgenommene vorsätzliche Sabotage einer
kritischen Infrastruktur ist äußerst
gefährlich und kann im Grunde als
Kriegsverbrechen oder terroristische Akt
eingestuft werden
an der Front ist Russland kurz davor ins
Gras zu beißen und hier im
Sicherheitsrat stürzen sie sich erneut
in einen Schlamm aus Lügen
im Ort von Valeri Melnik beginnt der
Wasserstand laut russischen Behörden
bereits zu sinken er will bleiben
irgendwann sagt er müsse der Krieg ja
mal zu Ende gehen
für uns in harson ist weiterhin Tim
Krüger Tim wie gehen die Menschen mit
der Katastrophe um bekommen sie
ausreichend Hilfe
also wir haben hier heute den ganzen Tag
Rettungsaktion gesehen das sind immer
wieder Menschen evakuiert worden vor
allem hier im Stadtteil coravel und ich
hatte den Eindruck dass diese
Hilfsmaßnahmen sehr ruhig sehr
professionell abgelaufen sind und auch
der Umgang der Menschen mit dieser
Situation war beeindruckend auch sie
wirkten relativ gefasst und sie haben
uns erzählt dass sie hier in Carson
schon so viel erlebt haben dass sie
jetzt mit dieser Situation auch umgehen
können dazu muss man vielleicht wissen
dass Rastern direkt nach Kriegsbeginn
von den Russen besetzt wurde dass die
Stadt dann mehrere Monate später befreit
wurde aber dass die Stadt auch nach der
Befreiung hier massiv beschossen wurde
die ganze Zeit und jetzt kommen eben
diese verheerenden Wassermassen dazu
also die Menschen in Kasern haben schon
viel mitgemacht und ich habe den
Eindruck dass die die bis jetzt
geblieben sind sich in dieser Situation
auch nicht ins boxhandler jagen lassen
dass sie auch nicht aufgeben vielen Dank
für diesen Bericht von Tim Krüger war
das
das Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
hilft den Menschen auch im
Überschwemmungsgebiet sie können die
Arbeit der Organisationen unterstützen
Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Ukraine iban.de
65100-400-100-400 alle Infos unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf
Seite 890
es ist eine Probe für den Ernstfall und
ein Signal Richtung Moskau er die Fender
23 heißt das internationale
luftwaffenmanöver ab Montag am Himmel
über Deutschland 10 Tage lang gibt es
unter deutscher Führung Übungseinsätze
rein defensiv so wird betont neben
hunderten von Flugzeugen sind mehr als
10.000 Soldaten und Soldatinnen
beteiligt Andreas
es ist alles vorbereitet auf dem
Fliegerhorst dem niedersächsischen
Wunstorf die Tanklager gefüllt alle
Notfallübungen absolviert wohnstorf wird
zum Drehkreuz für das größte
internationale militär-luftmanöver in
der Geschichte
treibstoffersatzteile Verpflegung
Logistik ist hier gefragt das Ganze
unter deutscher Führung es wird alles
zum Üben gehen da sein wo sein soll aber
bis dahin wird es tatsächlich noch ein
Stück Arbeit sein dass er sich alles
pünktlich an den Standorten eintrifft wo
es auch ein Treffen soll er die Fender
das heißt 250 Flugzeuge gut 10000
Soldatinnen und Soldaten aus 25 Staaten
über 2000 Flüge sind geplant das
Übungsszenario Verteidigung des NATO
Luftraums
das ist eine defensive Übung zu zeigen
dass dieses Bild ist in der Lage sich zu
verteidigen wenn es sein müsste rein
defensiv also doch mit Finger zeigt
Richtung Russland sie her wir wissen uns
zu verteidigen niemand solle die Stärke
der nato-allianz unterschätzen so die
amerikanische Botschafterin
wenn irgendein Staats und reg
ierung nicht zur Kenntnis nehmen würde
was das im Hinblick auf den Geist dieser
Allianzen heißt im Hinblick auf ihre
Stärke das meint auch Herrn Putin
nach jahrelanger Planung beginnt ab
Montag dann 10 Tage lang eher Defender
klar ist der Himmel über Deutschland
wird dann voller Auswirkungen auf die
zivile Luftfahrt wie Flugausfälle oder
Verspätungen nicht ausgeschlossen
Sorge um den Papst der 86-Jährige wurde
am Nachmittag an der Bauchdecke operiert
nach Angaben des Vatikan hatte den
dreistündigen Eingriff gut überstanden
noch am Vormittag hatte franziskus auf
dem Petersplatz seine Generalaudienz
abgehalten im Papa mobil begrüßte er die
Gläubigen das Kirchenoberhaupt wird
mehrere Tage in der Klinik bleiben vor
zwei Jahren hatte franziskus bereits
eine Darm-OP
nach Brasilien dort wird Außenministerin
bärburg gerade für eine engere
Zusammenarbeit zwischen Südamerika und
Europa konkret geht es um den Abschluss
eines Handelsabkommens der EU mit den
Merkur starten dazu gehören neben
Brasilien noch Argentinien Paraguay und
Uruguay kommt das Abkommen Zustande
würde eine der größten Freihandelszonen
entstehen mit mehr als 700 Millionen
Menschen doch noch ist es nicht so weit
Streit gibt es besonders beim
Umweltschutz Andrea Maurer
die Außenministerin unterwegs in
Brasiliens Amazonasgebiet die Zerstörung
des Regenwaldes ist für das Weltklima
eine Katastrophe für die Menschen hier
ist der Wald Lebensgrundlage
es ist nicht notwendig den Wald zu roden
wenn wir ihn nur nachhaltig nutzen
bei bärbox Brasilien Reise geht es auch
um das umstrittene Merkur
Handelsabkommen mehr Handel zerstört den
Regenwald noch mehr fürchten
Umweltorganisationen und lehnen das
Abkommen radikal ab
das Handelsabkommen fördert noch mal
alle klimaschädlichen Produkte die wir
eigentlich nicht mehr haben wollen
Fleisch Pestizide verbrennerautos
die EU schlägt zwar eine Waldschutz
Zusatzerklärung vor die aber geht auch
den deutschen Grünen nicht weit genug
sie wollen schärfere
Sanktionsmechanismen die die
merkursstaaten wiederum als Einmischung
empfinden die grüne Außenministerin
wirkt in Brasilien offensiv für ein
Abkommen auf Augenhöhe und deswegen habe
ich sehr genau hingehört mit Blick auf
die vielen Fragen die es gegeben hat von
mir starten nicht nur von
Umweltverbänden auf die Frage was
bedeutet eigentlich Sanktionen wenn
Klimaziele nicht eingehalten werden und
einige Länder haben das so verstanden
dass es nur bedeutet wir als Europäer
würden dann Maßnahmen ergreifen aber es
gilt andersrum ja genauso die
Bundesregierung braucht eine gemeinsame
Position für den Europäischen Rat
Annalena bärburg macht hier in Brasilien
klar sie ist für das Abkommen am besten
noch in diesem Jahr sonst setzen hier
andere die Standards etwa China
die EU und die merkursur-staaten schauen
nun sehr genau wie sich Deutschland
positioniert
die EU geht einmal mehr wegen eines
umstrittenen Gesetzes gegen Polen vor
und hat ein entsprechendes Verfahren
eröffnet nach dem Gesetz dürfen Personen
keine öffentlichen
Ämter mehr übernehmen wenn ihnen von
einer Kommission russlandfreundliche
Politik nachgewiesen wird kritiker
fürchten dass damit aussichtsreiche
Oppositionspolitiker wie
Ex-Regierungschef tuskalt gestellt
werden sollen vor den anstehenden
Parlamentswahlen im Herbst
erst gab es leichte Entwarnung doch am
Nachmittag hat sich die Lage im
Waldbrandgebiet südlich von Berlin
wieder verschärft der Grund starker Wind
auf dem ehemaligen Truppenübungsplatz
bei Jüterbog hat die Einsatzleitung nun
zusätzliche Feuerwehrleute alarmiert es
soll auch wieder aus der Luft gelöscht
werden gut 300 Hektar Wald sind
betroffen Antje klingt bei
schon mehrere Tage brennt dieses
Waldgebiet in Jüterbog betroffen sind
gut 300 Hektar Fläche die Feuerwehr kann
nur die Ortschaften schützen ein
Löscheinsatz direkt auf dem früheren
Truppenübungsplatz der
starkmunitionsbelastet ist wäre zu
gefährlich wir rechnen heute wieder mit
Temperaturen doch knapp an die 30 Grad
dran all die Situation hat sich nicht
verbessert eher in der Situation
aktuell so verschlechtert dass wir damit
rechnen müssen dass dieser Brand noch
lange nicht zu Ende ist
damit das Feuer nicht noch mehr Raum
gewinnt Brandenburg ist eines der
trockensten Bundesländer der zukommen
6000 Hektar munitionsbelastete Fläche
Wald zu schützen ist hier eine
Jahrhundertaufgabe deshalb ist unsere
Forderung an dem Bund dass er verstärkt
auch Einstieg zu munitionsberäumung das
wird bisher allerdings vom Bund
abgelehnt aber wir bleiben bei unserer
Forderung eigentlich sollte sich dieses
Gebiet zu einem Urwald entwickeln nun
wird das Biotop zumindest teilweise
zerstört
Kraft tanken in einer schwierigen Zeit
das will der Evangelische Kirchentag den
teilnehmenden ermöglichen 100.000 Gäste
werden bis Sonntag in Nürnberg erwartet
auch Bundespräsident und Bundeskanzler
die Haltung der Kirche zum Krieg wird
ebenso Thema sein wie Klimaschutz KI und
der Mitgliederschwund aus Franken
berichtet Alexander Pohl
auch das ist Kirche die Hochzeit von
Kana auf der Jesus Wasser in Wein
verwandelt neu inszeniert
Stefanie sardin ist Pfarrerin in der
Gemeinde St Michael in Fürth seit Tagen
Proben Sie hier für den Kirchentag
Kirchengemeinde das ist ja viel mehr das
ist ja nicht nur ein Gottesdienst das
sind ganz viele Gruppen ganz viele
Aktivitäten wechselseitige Unterstützung
und da
floriert unsere Gemeinde und dennoch
auch wenn gerade Tausende in Nürnberg
den Beginn des Kirchentags feiern das
Bild von der großen weltumspannenden
Gemeinschaft hat Risse vor allem die
vielen Missbrauchskandale erschüttern
die Gemeinden untertausende haben der
Kirche den Rücken gekehrt und doch muss
sie Antworten geben auf die Klimakrise
etwa oder die Frage wie sie sich im
Ukraine kriegt verhält ich bin selbst
gerade in KF gewesen und ich habe erlebt
wie der Luftalarm losgegangen ist nachts
und die Menschen in Kiefer werden nur
deswegen geschützt und viele Menschen
leben werden gerettet weil es
Flugabwehrraketen gibt deswegen kann ich
nicht dagegen sein dass Menschen vor
solchen verbrecherischen Raketen
Angriffen auf zivilen geschützt werden
viele hier auf dem Nürnberger Hauptmarkt
denken ähnlich die Haltung der Kirche
muss nach wie vor eine passe festliche
sein nicht desto trotz äh die Russland
ist völkerrechtswidrig in den Ukraine
einmarschiert und wer darf der Ukraine
verwehren sich zu werden
Standortbestimmung eine wichtige Aufgabe
für den diesjährigen Kirchentag in
Nürnberg
tja jetzt zur Fußball-Bundesliga
Relegation zweiter Teil Norbert wen
Wiesbaden aufgestiegen Bielefeld
abgestiegen schwerer Schlag für die
Arminia beide Relegationsspiele verloren
ungewisse Zukunft für den
Traditionsverein die Hessen dagegen
melden sich nach drei Jahren
Drittklassigkeit wieder zurück in Liga 2
ja und haben das heute daheim ordentlich
gefeiert
Fußball-Bundesliga WM Wiesbaden feiert
hoch verdient durch einen 2:1
Auswärtssieg im Relegation zurückspielen
dank zwei Toren von Benedikt Hollerbach
damit ist seine Vertragsverlängerung
übrigens fix im Hinspiel hatte das Team
von Trainer Markus Kaczynski die Arminia
schon 4:0 besiegt Bielefeld muss so nach
8 Jahren wieder in die dritte Liga und
wen in Wiesbaden spielt zum dritten Mal
in der Vereinsgeschichte zweitklassig
BVB-Star Jude Bellingham wechselt
kommende Saison zu Real Madrid die
Ablöse Summe für den 19-Jährigen 103
Millionen Euro plus Bonuszahlung ja und
Weltfußballer Lionel Messi wechselt nach
Medienberichten offenbar nun doch nicht
von Paris Saint-Germain nach Saudi
Arabien sondern in die USA zu Inter
Miami
Samstagabend Champions League Finale in
Istanbul Manchester City gegen Inter
Mailand die Engländer mit dem Star
Ensemble um Ilkay Gündogan und earling
Holland Clara Favorit es wäre das erste
Mal das City den Henkelpott gewinnen
würde
zwei Titel hat Ilka Gündogan in dieser
Saison bereits gewonnen nach der
Meisterschaft erzielte er beim 2:1 Sieg
im FE Cup Finale gegen den lokal Rivalen
United beide Tore in seinem dritten
Champions League Finale will der Sohn
türkische Eltern nun endlich die
Königsklasse gewinnen was er auch im
Interview mit ZDF Experte Per
Mertesacker macht und was sind deine
Gefühle dass das Spiel in Istanbul ist
ist das was besonderes für dich ich
glaube ich brauche den nicht sagen was
das bedeuten würde dann dort als Kapitän
ja die Trophäen in den Händen zu halten
gegen Inter Mailand sehen die Buchmacher
die Engländer klar vorne ungeschlagen
zog City ins Endspiel ein schaltete im
Viertelfinale auch die Bayern aus
heute in Athen die Flamme ist entzündet
der finale Countdown für die Special
Olympics hat begonnen die weltfestspiele
für Menschen mit geistiger und
mehrfacher Behinderung beginnen am 17
Juni in Berlin an neun Tagen werden dann
über 7.000 Athletinnen und Athleten aus
190 Ländern in 26 Sportarten
gegeneinander antreten übrigens das
größte multisport-event in Deutschland
seit Olympia München 1972 und ZDF und
ARD übertragen live vielen Dank ja gerne
in den Dschungel ist es manchmal gar
nicht weit derzeit gilt einfach nach
Mannheim fahren dort kreuzt eine innen
begrünte Straßenbahn die erste ihrer Art
sagt die Stadt quasi als mobiles
Plädoyer für grüne Nahverkehr und ein
bisschen auch als Werbung für die
dortige Bundesgartenschau wer es erleben
will muss schnell sein dass
dschungelgefühl auf Rädern gibt's nur
gut eineinhalb Wochen lang
und jetzt gibt es möglicherweise für den
einen oder anderen ein Glücksgefühl die
Lottozahlen sie lauten 17 19 30 33 40 49
und die Superzahl 6 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im
zdf-text auf Seite 557
morgen wird's heiß erstmals im Jahr
steigen die Werte hierzulande auf 30
Grad wo Gewitter dazu kommen erfahren
Sie gleich von Katja horneffer das heute
journal mit Marietta Slomka um 9:45 Uhr
[Musik]
guten Abend dieses Tief das
international Oscar heißt hat Madeira
hunderte Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter
gebracht etwas Regen viel heute auch bei
uns mit diesem kleinen tief das waren
aber doch nur Regenschauer und Gewitter
und die zogen von Südwesten auf vor
allen Dingen über die Mittelgebirge und
bis zum Nachmittag erreichten diese
Schauer und Gewitter auch
Nordrhein-Westfalen jetzt am Abend
werden die Gewitter immer mehr in sich
zusammenfallen und so kann es in der
Nacht höchstens noch ein paar
Regenschauer geben in Thüringen oder in
Sachsen sonst ist es häufig klar und
hier im Nordwesten oder auch im Saarland
bildet sich etwas Nebel die Temperaturen
singen auf 15 Grad in der Nähe von
Erfurt und 7 Grad in der Nähe von Kiel
und morgen strahlt die Sonne an der
Küste Richtung Mittelgebirge werden die
Wolken schon dichter und in den
Mittelgebirgen vor allen Dingen aber
auch in Süddeutschland gibt es zum Teil
heftige Schauer und Gewitter und da
diese Gewitter nur langsam ziehen können
Sie örtlich eng begrenzt auch stark
regnet mitbringen die Gewittergefahr ist
etwas geringer hier im Südwesten am
Oberrhein oder auch im Saarland die
Höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 18 Grad an der Nordsee bis zu
30 Grad rund um Berlin und an diesem
Wetter mit viel Sonnenschein und wenigen
schauen und Gewittern Süddeutschland
geht es dann weiter guten Abend